You know, when a computer starts up, it has
to boot – bootstrap, is what that means.
And that boot straps itself by continuing
to engage in more and more complex processes
as it starts up.
So, it starts up with a simple process, and
that triggers a more complex process.
And that triggers a more complex process,
and that way, the computer boots itself into
existence.
Well, that’s exactly what we did, except
we did it over like three billion years, right?
We started out as these unbelievably simple
organisms that can pretty much do nothing
at all, except replicate and develop much
more and more complex forms over this tremendously
long period of evolutionary history, right?
So, that’s how we solved the problem that
you can’t know anything without knowing
something, and that you can’t have knowledge
without generating it.
It’s: A little knowledge, a little more
generation.
A little knowledge, a little more generation.
A little knowledge-- this huge spiraling process
that expends-- extends over vast amounts of
time; information encoded in your body, right,
and as part of your-- as part of the nature
of your being; and information encoded in
your culture, reflected inside, you enacted
out in the world.
And as scientists, you know, with this 500-year
history of science behind us, we always believe
that it’s the material substrate of things
that’s the reality.
But it is more complicated than that, because
even the material substrate that we consider
as scientists isn’t merely unformed stuff,
right?
It has structure.
It’s patterned.
It’s full of information, and there are
physicists working now who believe that conceptualization
of the ground of being – the material ground
uh, of being – as information is a more
fruitful metaphor than conceptualization of
the ground of being as like unformed matter.
It’s not unformed, right?
It’s patterned and regular.
Informative so that if you investigate it,
it reveals order as not just a material structure.
So, if you go back to Democratus, right, the
person who originated the atomic hypothesis,
Democratus actually says two things – not
one.
He says: Everything’s made out of atoms
– little bits of stuff.
But the other thing he says is: Atoms array
themselves in space array themselves-- And
what that means is that the atomic structure
of things is patterned, and that the pattern
is just as real as the atoms themselves.
It’s the pattern that’s the knowledge,
right?
It’s the pattern that’s the information.
So, what we encounter as conscious beings
is this complexly patterned array, which we
then turn into knowledge – useable knowledge.
I said: Well, how would this metaphorical
representation work?
And so uh, the way I want you to look at this
figure is like this: Imagine this as distant,
right, as lurking in the background.
So, this is the ground of all being manifesting
itself as one primordial archetype, or one,
one metaph-- one standard motive metaphorical
representation.
Why this figure?
Well, this is complicated, I think.
If you show men a picture of a beautiful woman
with her eyes averted, while you’re doing
a brain scan mapping of their nucleus accumbens,
nothing happens.
Why is that relevant?
Well, the nucleus accumbens is part of the
underlying emotional circuitry that governs
approach behaviour and pleasure.
And approach behaviour and pleasure are very
tightly intertwined.
If you show the same man a picture of a beautiful
woman with her eyes locked on his, his nucleus
accumbens will light up.
Why is that?
Well, it’s partly because men are innately
in-- attuned to hu-- to female beauty.
Female beauty has a standard form.
It’s replicable cross-culturally.
It constitutes the average human…
human female form.
But more than that, the gaze-locking is an
indication of shared attention.
And it’s also the indication of the initial
establishment of a shared attentional space.
And it’s an invitation, and that invitation
activates approach circuitry, even if it’s
just a picture.
So, and you can see this if you walk into
any drug store, or any-any s-- any drug store
that sells magazines.
What do you see?
Well, in the men’s magazines, you see an
infinite array of beautiful women.
And in the female magazines, the women’s
magazines, you see an infinite array of beautiful
women.
Now, just exactly why is that?
Well, there’s something absolutely compelling
about female beauty.
And then, you have to ask yourself: What the
hell does compelling mean?
OK, so what compelling means is: You’re
busily engaged in a goal-directed task and
something happens in your peripheral vision,
so to speak, that attracts your attention.
Now, that attention is attracted by processes
that are fundamentally unconscious; which
means, processes that occur before you can
think.
So, you can imagine a loose collection of
college-aged males having a conversation in
a bar, when someone beautiful walks by.
And one or more of them catch her out of the
corner of their eyes.
Orientation, right?
Unconscious.
Why?
Because there’s something about that pattern
form that grips attentional systems and directs
observation towards it.
So then, you think: OK.
Human beings are really, really complicated
pattern processors.
And you think: Well, partly what we’re trying
to get a handle on here is the nature of the
world.
And partly what we know already is that there
are aspects of the world that you can’t
understand always.
And then, you think: Well, people are trying
to get a grip on the fact that there are parts
of the world that you can’t understand.
So, that there’s this transcendant element
to being that always escapes encapsulation.
How would you represent it?
Well, it’s the transcendent element of things
that always attracts your attention, implicitly,
beyond your control.
So, loud noise or a scream, or the cry of
a baby or anything horrific, right?
Blood, broken bodies…
These are stimuli that are so representative
of trouble that you can’t help but attend
to them.
And then, you can imagine that all the stimuli,
so to speak, that you can’t help but attend
to, can be amalgamated into representations
of… the transcendent aspect of reality.
And that’s what you see in this representation
right here.
So, you see a weird intermingling of female
sexuality, plus some very distinct genital
symbolism.
Why genital?
So, imagine that that’s a vulval opening.
Why?
Before we had any scientific knowledge at
all-- let’s go 10,000 years ago.
What the hell’s inside a body?
Well, we knew that, I guess, a little bit
from hunting, right?
We knew the interior of a body.
What is it about the interior of a body that
allows new forms to be generated?
How is it that mothers can give birth to children?
How is it that one form, that’s complex
and attractive and mysterious, can give rise
to another form?
Why is that useful knowledge from a representational
perspective?
Because there’s some association between
the feminine form from a metaphorical perspective,
and the capacity for nature to give rise to
new forms.
And then you see a representation of a typical
monstrous form that’s Kali the Hindu goddess
the devourer and in this representation so
she’s like a more developed version of Tiamat
that’s a good way of thinking about her.
She's not so much unspeakable anymore, you
can actually say a few things about Kali,
you could say well she’s like a spider because
she has 8 legs and she weaves a web of fate
and you could say well her web is made out
of fire because if you get too near to her
you'll burn up.
And you could say she glares at you with eyes
that are unblinking and you could say she
has a tongue like a tiger and you could say
that she carries weapons of destruction and
has a headdress of skulls and that her hair
is on fire.
And you could say that she’s giving birth
to this guy as nature gives birth to human
beings and is devouring him at the same time.
Intestines first.
And then you could say well you could imagine
that the first few people that made a representation
like that shocked themselves quite badly,
right because this is a this is a representation
of fear itself in a sense not exactly it’s
also a representation of those stimuli that
if you're human are going to make you both
afraid and compelled just like it’s hard
to look away from fire even if it’s burning
something down, you want to have it around.
Rats if you raise a rat to juvenile status
and then waft in cat odour it will completely
short circuit, why?
Well the rat’s never seen a cat so exactly
what the hell is it responding to you think
well you could say well it’s not a conditioned
stimulus because the rat’s never encountered
a cat there's something deep in the brain
of that rat that knows something about cat
odour has never encountered a cat so exactly
what is it perceiving well in some sense I
think the notion that it’s perceiving is
wrong it isn't perceiving, it’s just going
like this.
That’s the representation.
Well with chimpanzees who are more complex
there are other stimuli that evoke exactly
that kind of response chimps don’t like
snakes.
Dead or alive plastic rubber doesn’t matter
they don’t like snakes if you put one in
their cage they get as far away from the snake
as they can as quickly as possible and then
they look at it.
Because I suppose if you're a chimpanzee even
if you don’t like snakes it’s a good idea
to know where they are right so it’s simultaneously
repelling -- Ahh snake!
-- plus attractive well you better look at
it and see where it’s gonna go.
Chimpanzees don’t like unconscious chimpanzees
so if you knock a chimpanzee out with anesthetic
and you bring the body of the chimpanzee back
into the chimpanzee cage the chimps do exactly
the same thing away from the body but they
look at it they don’t like masks made of
chimpanzee faces.
Well 3 year old kids don’t like masks either.
there are these underlying perceptual primitive
so to speak that likely activate lower limbic
mechanisms in our brains that say to us this
is a place suddenly where something that you
probably do not like or will not like is very
very likely to happen so you can imagine that
an environment characterized by unconscious
bodies or blood or the presence of spiders
or snakes etcetera might be a place where
a primate such as yourself may encounter things
that they don’t know how to cope with therefore
afraid, right same with fear of the dark,
and then you can imagine that the dark is
populated with all of these monsters of the
unknown and you get some notion of what's
happening to children who are afraid of the
dark, why are they afraid of the dark.
Because in the dark which is the place you
don’t know lurk things that could hurt a
creature like you.
What things.
Well we can’t exactly say, but if you give
children exposure to books and to adult conversation
and the television soon those limbic structures
that are populating the darkness with unnamable
fear start to populate it up with skeletons
and vampires and monsters and so forth and
so on.
the representational structures that the brain
is capable of generating say well fear-inducing
things are like that they're bloody they're
dangerous they look like serpents they look
like insects they lurk in the dark they sneak
up on you etc. all mangled together into some
sort of monstrous form.
Now I wanna read you a story.
So lemme give you a little background on this
story.
This story popped into my head in one chunk
like complete which I thought was kind of
interesting but… it was also a story that
emerged in solution to a problem I’d been
thinking about for a long time because I was
dealing with this guy who didn't wanna grow
up, so he’s caught in a kind of Peter Pan
situation and Peter Pan, pan means everything,
pan like pantheistic.
And Peter Pan is a child who won’t grow
up now he’s magical well okay fine children
live in the magical world right they're ripe
with possibility, he’s magical.
He doesn’t wanna grow up.
So he lives in Neverland with the lost boys,
Neverland doesn’t really exist and the lost
boys are obviously boys who haven't managed
to establish some mode of being and he’s
in constant battle with Capt.
Hook and Capt.
Hook’s a tyrant right a pirate a negative
a manifestation of the negative archetype
of social order.
Hook is always fighting Peter Pan because
Peter Pan represents childhood and vulnerability
and he doesn’t wanna be vulnerable so they're
locked in this sort of eternal battle.
and lots of people I think more commonly men
but not necessarily, get caught in this Peter
Pan problem
So I was dealing with a person who was caught
in this situation didn't wanna grow up wouldn’t
sacrifice childhood.
And so this story popped into my head.
It’s called Cockadoodledo
Once upon a time there was a man who had a
long hard journey ahead of him.
He was trudging along the way over waters
and through brushes when he saw little shiny
gnome with big white teeth and a black toupee
sitting by the side of the road.
He was drumming on a log.
With two white bones and humming oddly to
himself.
The little gnome said John, why work so hard
why walk so fast.
Who knows if you'll ever get there anyway.
Come over here I have something to show you.
So John walked off the road.
He was sick of walking anyway because people
kept throwing sticks and stones at him.
Little gnome said I have a shiny red jewel
that I would like to sell you.
Cheap.
Here it is.
And from beneath his cloak he pulled the biggest
ruby that the man had ever seen.
Must’ve weighed 100 pounds and shone like
the sun.
The gnome said, do you like it.
It’s an enchanted stone, what will you offer
me for it.
And the man said.
I don’t have much, much money but I’ll
give you everything I have.
And the gnome looked displeased.
So John added I could pay some more monthly.
So the gnome accepted, fair enough buy now
pay later, sounds good for me, I'm all for
the installment plan.
So the man gave the gnome all his money and
promised to pay the rest later and the gnome
walked back into the bush by the road clacking
his teeth and giggling and twitching.
The more the man thought about this ruby and
the great deal he got the happier he became,
he started back on the road with a light heart
but soon discovered that he couldn't make
much progress because 100 pounds was a lot
to carry.
He said to himself why continue anyways I
have what I want, I’ll just stand here holding
my ruby and when people walk by they could
see how well I've all ready done.
So he stopped.
A little while one of his little while later
one of his friends came along saw him standing
there.
His friend said John why don’t you come
along with me.
I've just opened a new business and I could
really use some help, come along quick.
It will be opening soon.
John thought that sounded good.
But his friend was in a hurry.
Besides couldn't he see the ruby?
How could he speed along beside him where
would he put his jewel.
So he said thanks but I have to take care
of my jewel.
Maybe I’ll see you later.
His friend looked at him like he was crazy
but he was trying to get somewhere quick so
he just shrugged a bit and said okay John
see you later.
And he sped on down the road.
Little while later another friend came by
and he said John nice to see you.
I'm going back to school.
There are lots of wonderful things to learn,
great things to do.
The world is full of unsolved problems.
I could use some company.
Would you like to come along.
John thought that sounded pretty good but
this friend too looked like he was in a hurry.
Besides standing beside the road holding the
jewel was tiring and he needed all the energy
he had for that.
So he said to his friend thanks but I have
to take care of my jewel.
Isn't it beautiful maybe I’ll see you later.
His friend looked at him like he was crazy
but he was trying to get somewhere quick so
he just shrugged and said hope everything
goes all right with you, see you later.
Many friends came and went and the years went
by.
The jewel got heavier and heavier.
But the man got more and more attached to
it.
The only thing was nobody seemed to notice
how beautiful it was.
People would rush by and talk about their
plans and nobody had a ruby as big and nobody
seemed likely to get a ruby as big if you'd
think that someone might have said something
like at least nice ruby John sure wish I had
one like that but it never happened.
Then one day someone new came down the road,
he was bent over and he was thin and his hair
was gray, although he didn't look that old.
He was carrying a big dirty rock carefully
in his arms and he wasn’t making much progress.
The strange figure approached and glanced
up at John, then he grinned and said, why
are you standing there so stupidly with a
big ugly rock in your tired old hands.
You look pretty daft.
I bet you wish you had a big ruby like the
one I'm carrying and John thought this poor
man is deluded, he’s carrying a rock.
I have the ruby so he said excuse me sir but
you were sadly mistaken.
I'm the one with the jewel I met a little
gnome by the side of the road and he sold
it to me.
I’m still paying for it.
Although not so very much, you are carrying
a rock.
The tired stranger looked annoyed said I don't
know what game you're playing mister you have
a rock I have a jewel.
Little gnome you described sold it to me.
And he said it was the only one.
I've been carrying it for 20 years.
And I’ll never let it go.
And John said but I'm been carrying mine for
20 years too, it can’t be just a rock.
Rock or jewel on and on they argued.
Suddenly out stepped the little gnome as if
he’d never left.
Only this time he wasn’t so little he was
bigger and redder and menacing and his laugh
sounded like the rattling of chains.
Quit arguing you two.
I've never seen a sight quite so pathetic.
You're carrying rocks, both of you.
And if you would've ever had the sense to
put them down for a second or two you would've
seen that.
Oh well at least you were diligent.
I played a mean trick.
I feel bad.
So I'm gonna give you what you really deserve.
Do you want what you really deserve?
And John and the thin stranger nodded eagerly,
finally they thought.
You haven't seen anything yet.
Throw down your rocks.
So John and the thin stranger obeyed.
Each rock split down the middle and it hit
the ground, out flowed a river of ravenous
white worms which rushed towards the men and
devoured them whole while they thrashed about
and screamed.
Soon nothing was left except a legbone from
each.
The little gnome picked them up and walked
off the road.
He sat down by a hollow log and started to
drum.
He drummed and he waited.
And he hummed an odd little tune.
Picture of food feeds the whole hungry clan,
the image of good makes the whole healthy
man, why walk for miles why do the work, just
smile the smile, success after all is a quirk,
life isn't real that’s the message I give.
It’s easy that way, plus who wants to live?
So needless to say the guy that I was telling
this story to never listened to it and things
really didn't go well for him for a long,
long time, and they really didn't go well
for him until he was willing to give up some
of the things he was carrying along so he
had acquired for example a number of things
that he couldn't afford.
And the fact that he was carrying them right
paying for them month after month, meant couldn't
afford to get an education was perfectly willing
to sacrifice the possibility of getting an
education for the image of success.
Rather than the reverse right and he was completely
irritated at the world because he had all
these trappings of success which no one he
admired also admired and he absolutely wasn’t
getting anywhere and he thought that was tremendously
unfair.
But the truth of the matter was that had he
put down what he was carrying for even a moment
and he would've been able to get to where
he wanted to go.
And that’s a motif that succinctly and dramatically
describes the necessity for sacrifice.
Now one of the things you see in psycho therapy
very very commonly is that the person who’s
coming for help does the same damn thing over
and over and over and every time they do it,
it has the same consequence.
Bad.
So they end up with the same kind of they
end up in the same kind of relationship.
Right starts out well then the person turns
against them and starts to abuse them they
get abused repeatedly then it ends then they
meet someone else and the cycle continues
doesn’t seem to matter who they're out with
either they pick a person like this or they
turn the person into someone like that they
lose jobs the same way or their educational
hopes fail the same way, why, well the person
thinks man… the structure of the world is
so unfair everyone else seems to be getting
along just fine but me I get hit in the head
over and over.
Exactly the same way and then you think well…
what is the structure of the world, exactly
and then you remember well you know there's
the things you don’t understand and the
things you do understand and the things you
do understand structure you and protect you
but you know sometimes the things you do understand
aren't the right things, you're valuing something
you're carrying something that’s an impediment
to your further progress and it’s frequently
the case that it’s the kind of impediment
that under no conditions do you wanna give
up because there's something about you that
says like John says about the ruby, look,
it’s a ruby, who the hell cares if it weighs
100 pounds and I have to stand by the road
I still got the ruby, and all you'd ever have
to do is put the damn thing down and wander
off and everything would be just fine
but you won’t do it, why.
Because you don’t wanna give up what you
know.
Because you don’t wanna sacrifice anything.
Well, long before people had any psychological
acumen or any psychological knowledge they
all ready figured out that if you were gonna
take on a figure like this and expect to get
absolutely anywhere with her right the horrors
of the world, you bloody well better be willing
to sacrifice whatever’s necessary to keep
you going along your path right unfortunately
the things that you have to sacrifice are
often those things that you're most particularly
compelled by or gripped by or value the things
that you wanna give up least.
Which is why in archaic societies where all
this is dramatized people sacrifice an animal
that they value particularly.
Or eerier than that even a child that they
value particularly right dramatically portraying
the idea of sacrifice you have to give something
up if you wanna make an inroad on what she
represents.
And so then you say the purpose of sacrifice
is to turn the terrible aspect of the world
into the benevolent aspect of the world and
this is Diana not a Hindu goddess but a Greek
a Roman goddess same idea applies in the Hindu
case if you make the appropriate sacrifices
then the terrible aspect of the world turns
into the benevolent aspect of the world.
And it is the case that even empirical studies
of success indicate that intelligence is a
handy thing to have, but hard work and dedication
is a handy thing to have too and what that
means is that you're constantly willing to
sacrifice the impulsive pleasure of the present
for the hopes of payback in the future.
For example the sacrifice immediate gratification
to obtain an appropriate social role take
your place in society.
It’s definitely a sacrifice right because
you put off pleasures in the moment to obtain
long term stability and productivity.
To turn the world into this.
And so then you can say, this is how the world
falls apart as it’s explored right so first
of all there's the thing that you can’t
even name that only fills you with dread and
but also with the sense of possibility and
that manifests itself in your life as something
concrete.
That you don’t know promising and threatening
and that divides itself up into those aspects
of the world that you value and admire and
that hold promise for you, and those aspects
of the world that don’t and that’s a differentiation
as a consequence of exploration.
It’s not a differentiation of the world
into objects though it’s a differentiation
of the world into categories of emotion, those
things that are good for you those things
that are bad for you and the source that they're
derived from.
That’s the background of the world.
We'll stop!